open bar jon seidel opal has been
building compact cars for about 80 years
says are calm and I hold the cadet made
its debut in 1936 in 1991 it became the
Astra now opel aims to move closer to
the top of the compact class that means
class topping connectivity a new design
and LED matrix headlights that's
something only opal offers in this class
we'll see if it can deliver damn it
vaguely testing a list of kid valvular
to life isn't in mid-october the fifth
generation opel astra goes on sale
upwards of just over seventeen thousand
euros in germany three gasoline engines
and one diesel unit are available we
tested the 1.4 liter gasoline engine
with 110 kilowatts it's prints from 0 to
100 km/h in 8.5 seconds manufacturers
fuel consumption is 5.1 litres per 100
kilometers
or the enormous commitment the interior
is completely new says Reinhold and the
designers have responded to criticism
that the center console was cluttered
with controls there's enormous head room
in the Astra the optional ergonomic
high-performance seats are comfortable
over long distances Albert's commands
off cazando houghton and talented member
Chris the agreement on a language
stagnant at mankind I no one finds the
back massage too gentle the Audi a8 is
much better no it's in a completely
different league avodart smooth Delhi no
no guns under and Liga the new model
addresses many of the outgoing versions
issues a completely new platform meant
it could make big improvements with an
overall length of four point three seven
meters the new model is just under five
centimeters shorter than its predecessor
the wheelbase has also shrunk by two
centimeters even so there is now more
room inside
the interior was an interesting journey
for us so we came from a very good car
and in this car we wanted to first drive
the principles of sculptural artistry
meets German precision again our design
philosophy evolved again but there were
a couple of things that we wanted to do
simplicity clarity and efficiency was
our mantra the changes in the interior
are immediately apparent the confusing
array of buttons is a thing of the past
behind the three-spoke steering wheel
are for easy-to-read dials and a large
information display
light was one of the engineers top
priorities opal offers optional full LED
matrix headlights which it calls intelli
lux that's a first in the compact class
the smart lips lished opals English
Schneider says the matrix lines offer
one hundred percent high beams outside
of urban areas these are full LED
headlights that adjust to driving
conditions the camera watches for
oncoming traffic enough of the 16
segments are turned off so as to avoid
dazzling approaching vehicles or those
ahead Perkins could win the bid
technical innovations such as matrix
lights and the OnStar assist system see
the new Astra throwing down the gauntlet
to the competition then I asked are some
blind hold says there are lots of good
things about the new Astra fresh design
new engines reduce weight LED matrix
headlights and OnStar the Astro isn't
just safer it's also more convenient in
contrast the sat-nav gets a minus point
since the screen view changes much too
slowly in city traffic feel too long Sam
stanzi Frank car tester Andre invites us
to imagine that Subaru the world's
biggest maker of all wheel drive cars
got together with Toyota unofficially
the world's leading hybrid maker what
kind of car would come out of that
probably one of the sportiest rear-wheel
drive coupe a is going it's called the
Toyota gt86 and together with its
siblings it's the only car in existence
that combines a front-mounted boxer
engine with rear-wheel drive the gt86 is
Toyota's first sports car in 10 years
that's a long time for fans to build
expectations when mums ischium internet
buddy Andre claims that if you read
about the gt86 in internet forums you'll
find many contributors saying it doesn't
have enough power but at 200 horsepower
to a 1200 kilogram clear Boyd it's quite
adequate for sporty driving Spartacus
fan p levert % gaps and respects that
not having a turbo engine with powerful
talk might scare buyers off but the
linear performance figures of the gt86
is normally aspirated engine won him
over he had fun testing the engines
entire speed range
the four-cylinder engine is demanding
but rewards the driver inside with a
thoroughly robust sound it makes the
leap from 0 to 100 km/h in 7.6 seconds
our test yielded an average fuel
consumption of eight and a half liters
just slightly above the makers rating of
7.8 even after a ferry rollicking jaunt
for the Spotless your final for sporty
driving over country roads android
strongly recommends the gt86 SVSC sport
mode which lets the driver explore the
rear wheel drives dynamics the vehicle
stability control cut some slack on the
lateral acceleration but jumps in to
keep the car from drifting into
dangerous situations but if the driver
wishes to test his own abilities on a
track he can turn off the electronic
stability program completely and fish
tail around the curves only once and you
know master an axial load distribution
of 53 247 gives this Toyota almost
perfect balance that in the low center
of gravity allowed by the boxer engine
add up to vastly improved handling
and these are daily occurrence my name's
history and ray says he could stop right
here and say the gt86 is perfect for
young people looking for a starter
sports car model with rear-wheel drive
but that'd be only half the story
because people who choose rear-wheel
drive for their first car normally want
to use it for everyday driving and
that's just where the gt86 reveals its
weaknesses those weaknesses are most
apparent in the interior purists might
miss the oil gauge next to the easily
readable centrally placed tachometer
while others will complain about the
small GPS screen beyond uncomfortable is
the legroom for the back seats there
isn't any which renders them virtually
unusable
invited us out and I found something
else that makes the gt86 less than ideal
for everyday driving the location of the
electric window switches intuitively he
would look for them at arm's length on
the doors armrest but they're further
forward so he has to reach around the
handle he finds that a bit annoying and
not entirely safe while driving the
sheer agony good thing outside snappy
streamlined contours accentuate the
sports cars design
borrowed from motorsports are the raised
sides on the top to allow more Headroom
for helmets and if anybody wonders why
such a small engine would have such
large tailpipes their 86 millimeter
diameter is a veiled tribute to the
series number rainford in practice and
Jay thinks the gt86 will be more
practical if it had a large hatchback
reaching up to the roof and opening
upward but Toyota's only put out a
modest version with a relatively narrow
opening so if something happens to fall
into the trunk it takes long arms to
reach it practicality isn't the gt86 his
strong point but for purists or people
looking for a sporty second car he
thinks it might be just right yeah denk
ich can notice wish to go
Portia has a long history in Motorsports
it's the biggest and most successful
manufacturer in international sports car
racing and the mean machines made in
Stuttgart have a faithful following
around the world including the US the
Porsche rennsport reunion series named
after the car makers racing division has
become a pilgrimage for fans this fit
installment was hosted at the laguna
seca raceway in california in September
as always there are massive queues at
the Porsche souvenir store
yeah there's around 50,000 spectators
this year explains host Detlef von
platen there's no other event like this
in the US he reckons or perhaps the
world I love it fans can get up real
close to champion cars from yesteryear
and the men who drove them
lemoore winner and Joakim stuck has
never seen so many Porsche enthusiasts
in one place again porsche are the only
manufacturers in the world that could
ever put on an event like this because
they've been there ever since the day
they rolled a wheel yeah Formula One
race ace Jochen mass is mightily
impressed at seeing the panic full with
beautiful cars from his time good
through the years the rent sports
festival as grow up giant Lee but what
is fascinating is the aura of Borgia
true the spectators but there is action
on the track too of course and the
drivers take no prisoners laguna seca
might have a picturesque setting but
it's a daunting course with one
particularly ominous section
one was racing legend jurgenbot says you
have to approach slowly and then you
drive around the bend with one foot held
up it's a lot of fun it's called the
corkscrew which explains pretty well how
to drive it and flush and open up when
he knows it was a fun at the wheel of
the current 911 rsr Cup car is factory
driver gurg Bergmeister he says Europe
mostly has standard formula 1 tracks
where mistakes no longer have major
consequences here in the US safety is a
bit like in the old days he says he
thinks is good if you're punished for
your mistakes by man feel I'm a bit more
finished after the parade of vintage
races is a delight from the fans and
their heroes heads me racing veteran
hands you are him stuck says it brings
back lovely memories of his first limahl
win it still gives him goosebumps
driving here and it's the highlight of
his ear well over a hundred cars are
entered in the various races among them
a number of treasures from the porsche
museum associated Klaus Bischoff is the
director and he says it's always an
exciting occasion with the best cars and
the best drivers and then they're off
rolling back the years and the
kilometers and it's a thrill a minute
for the drivers the Porsche and spot
reunion is a unique event and reflects
the massive following Porsche has in the
US
well it's really a lifestyle it's it's a
very very intense relationship but
taking my case I i had a 951 and in
seattle in in minneapolis minnesota and
when we moved to Chicago the first thing
I did was to call people in Chicago from
the Porsche Club and say okay what
really what realtor do i go to see what
city should i be looking for a home and
if i want to go to dinner I'm new to the
sound weird like where do I eat and so
you it's a very very intense
relationship between the Porsche Club
members all over the country and 115,000
members in 175 clubs illustrate the
intense relationship of Americans to
Porsche on the first day the public are
treated to the premiere of the new 911
in North America
avocent studs-up chief engineer August
at leitner and his team are proud of the
new car yet again fire built he sure
everyone who drives it will enjoy it
next robotics and fundamental by a
multi-stage bus besides more power the
turbocharged engines are more efficient
bending her system fuel economy is after
twelve percent battery says which is in
keeping with the times the new 911 is
already eagerly awaited in the US
yeah he says American customers don't
just go cruising down highways they take
the car out around the racetrack more
often than Germans do they really do
have the Motorsports bug soon the new
911 will be gracing the racetracks of
the us here at Laguna however it's the
blasts from the past that the fans are
focusing on at the Porsche and Sport
reunion
on our quest for a drive technology
that's both environmental and economical
we tried out the Leon St 1.4 TGI by C at
it has a bivalent or buy fuel engine
meaning it runs on both natural and
normal gas the tanks are under the car
and inside the trunk floor one hold some
15 kilos of natural gas the other takes
50 liters of gasoline for a combined
range of 1,300 kilometers under the hood
is the 1.4 liter engine which after some
technical adjustments runs on both fuel
types
the TGI delivers 81 kilowatts of power
see at rates fuel consumption at three
and a half kilos per hundred kilometers
emitting less than 100 grams of co2 per
kilometer these numbers sound easy on
the environment and the Wyatt at the
current price of one euro four cents per
kilo of natural gas that adds up to just
under three euros 7400 km/h reviewer
mattes concedes that with this engine
the Leon St is no rocket 81 kilowatts
are enough to keep up with traffic and
even manage an occasional sprint as long
as there's natural gas in the tank that
by valent Leon's engine will use it
instead of the gasoline
no movie italic ina and Mathis assures
potential drivers that they needn't
worry about complicated switchovers once
the natural gas is used up the car
automatically changes to gasoline power
but you want to get to a natural gas
fueling station as soon as possible
since driving on normal fuel costs more
money when the tank is empty we head to
a CNG or compressed natural gas station
just how economical is the Leon in
practice and is it really as green as
the manufacturers figures indicate and
just over a euro per kilogram the
advantage over fossil fuels is obvious
but do drivers really save that much on
the road yet I'm filling the tank with
natural gas is almost the same process
as with normal fuel down below are two
receptacles one for premium gasoline and
one for natural gas einen air cars so
you just take the natural gas nozzle
connect it
unger dog press the button wait until
the tank is filled the tank fullest in
Germany it costs about 16 and a half
euros to fill the tank with natural gas
hindi aveda when the nozzle is
disconnected there's a little hiss and
then you're done on the sparse ocean
then there's a little surprise then land
vida at gas detector once the natural
gas tank is full this little green
indicator in the tachometer shows the
car is switched back it displays a range
of 260 kilometres on natural gas gas
p'tee pun this is but that's
considerably less than what see on
promises which was a range of some 400
kilometers on natural gas for a total
range of 1,300 kilometers together with
gasoline power this is where the theory
diverges from the practice found it's
slightly disappointing what ethnic
abduct matters has no serious complaints
about the sea at Leon St the suspension
is well balanced the engine is free
revving without guzzling gas and the
workmanship is high quality but who are
the buyers for this car there aren't
that many natural gas stations in Europe
date that's eyes it's most need one on
your way to work for example and for
longer trips the driver has to plan the
route in advance so it passes close to a
natural gas station os10 moon long
favored damn it denis de Arges tongue
Stella Nick sous vide burgers
in our test the alternative fuel cost
nearly six euros 40 per hundred
kilometers but the small tank means
frequent refueling stops and the
additional 1800 euro costs over the
gasoline-powered Leon has to be covered
before it starts saving anything
the VW Beetle sold over 21 and a half
million units over its record-breaking
65-year history the very last beetle
came off the production line at vw's
plant in Puebla Mexico in 2003
indisputably this is the cult car from
Germany
up not socializing the first prototypes
appeared in 1935 explains our car man
Christopher but the Second World War cut
short plans for mass production that
finally got underway in 1945 the
starting year of an amazing success
story carefully mustn't polity 80 damn
it begins and it wouldn't cloudy here
folks 50 this vehicle is certainly not
the product of mass manufacture it was
one of ten models hand-built not involve
ugh or Mexico but in Switzerland this
extremely rare species of beetle goes by
the name volkswagen boiler pick up it
was born in nineteen fifty
okay let's fighting babe he says after
the war German industry was at rock
bottom people had to improvise and work
with whatever they had what they had was
the beetle so someone got the idea of
using the dependable VW as the basis for
a van what every transporter needs is a
cargo bed mounting this rather bulky
component on the rounded rear of the
beetle in a halfway elegant manner
required an artistic touch Swiss coach
maker boiler was up to the task even if
folks I can pick up in addition to the
van slyke we pick up widely also made
small station wagons based on the beetle
this pickup can carry a load of up to
380 kilograms the weight of another five
passengers bad with its 25 horsepower
Christoph isn't too sure whether it can
get going at all
he would sing that for my Portland he
says the boiler company had its roots in
the construction of fancy sports coupe
A's and convertibles a body works like
that or nay George ro and pininfarina so
when it was asked to build a commercial
vehicle it added a touch of elegance the
split rear window was replaced by a
single rectangle but look how this cargo
platform Nestle's on this shapely rear
and then there's still a canvas sunroof
it's as luxurious of pickup as you could
get even though it was born in the Swiss
town of poon there's no denying this
beatles roots the striking rear with the
iconic split oval window had to give way
to the loading area thanks to their good
connections brother zan stand foot
spoiler received the basic shells direct
from VW's German factory
the delicate two spoke steering wheel
and all kinds of chrome embellishments
show these beetles were really the more
expensive export version
once you're him here in the back is the
legendary VW boxer engine with 1.1 liter
displacement and 18 kilowatts of power
you'd really like to show but that's not
easy because you have to unhook the
cover here and squeeze it's a bit fiddly
he wonders how another three hundred 80
kilograms would affect the car with so
much weight on the rear axle already
would the front wheels stay on the road
you could hardly a wish for a better
commercial vehicle engine worldwide the
air called an unpretentious VW boxer
enjoyed a reputation of absolute
reliability you'll probably never see
the beetle pick up on public roads the
German Swiss project came to an end
after only a few were built their fight
song boy pick up he says the false wagon
point l'apicio tough competition from
its own ranks in 1952 a flatbed version
of the VW bus went on the market it
could haul 900 kilograms and cost less
than the hand-built beetle pick up so
it's no wonder that just under a dozen
were produced and pointer itself used
the first five male snappers boots
identity on the Aston film is only for
my boy trouser gossips as things two are
gonna start
the reason was simple the price of 8,000
swiss francs was out of reach of most
small businesses in 1950 even if it was
a commercial flop the concept of the VW
boiler pickup was groundbreaking
yeah volkswagen point he says the
Volkswagen boiler pickup is an
impressive example of the VW beetles
versatility who would have thought that
a few Swiss body workers could transform
this little car into a bona fide a
workhorse it also said a shining example
for later small vans from VW such as the
free Dolan which hold mail bags in
Germany for decades it's clear the
Volkswagen boiler pickup is a milestone
in automotive history a milestone the
Delta mobile ecosystem and because it's
so rare the VW boiler pickup is much
more expensive today than in the early
1950s early and exotic Beatles today
have a very large following
you